I met Sal when he was a 10th grader at
Grace King High School.
He was in my Algebra Two class.
That was a kid who challenged me,
he was a natural leader
as far as getting other
kids involved and active.
- Oh man, you teaching AP Calculus now?
- That's right, I am.
- Really, awesome! Oh man, I
would've brought you on stage!
- No!
- No seriously, I didn't
know you were here!
This guy, he wrote my
recommendations for college,
like honestly like none
of this would've happened.
- No.
- I don't know what to
do, I feel like crying.
- No, I'm crying.
This guy really hasn't changed one bit.
It's still the same Sal Mankan
that I saw in high school.
Down to earth, easy going, accessible,
nothing pretentious about him, okay.
And that's one of the
things that really makes
Khan Academy what it is.
It's like you know,
the whole thing is like the
gift that keeps on giving.
Which I think what education is about.